uh you know we we spoke uh last week
about how many companies
that were celebrating pride month
have a long history of donating to
homophobic politicians i want to now
follow up on a story that we talked
about uh some time ago several months
ago
the company boeing
has quietly resumed donating to the
republican traders that some know as the
sedition caucus
this is a daily beast article which
outlines what's going on really well
let's take a look at it and it says
after briefly swearing off political
donations in the wake of the capital
riot boeing is now throwing cash at
officials who fought to overturn the
results of the 2020 election in a recent
filing with the federal election
commission
boeing's political action committee
reported major contributions to three
republican members of congress who voted
to challenge the results of the
electoral college steve scalise
disgusting guy
and then the lesser known vicky hartzler
and jack bergman the report being
boeing's first to show political
contributions after the assault on the
capital also disclosed a twenty five
thousand dollar gift to the republican
attorneys general association whose
fundraising armed hell arm helped
promote the january sixth rally to quote
stop the steal boeing contributed less
than half that amount to the
organization's democratic counterpart
boeing gave scalise and hartzler each
five thousand dollars the limit for an
election bergman a michigan conservative
who in december pushed erroneous claims
of election fraud in his home state got
half of that amount boeing previously
donated to all three now the article
does go on to say boeing also gave money
to democratic officials like nancy
pelosi as well as republicans who did
vote to certify the election results the
aerospace and defense giant also gave
the maximum 105 000 dollars to both
parties house and senate campaign
committees
this is what people really have to
understand about this first of all the
headline is boeing quietly resumes
donating to republican uh you know to
the sedition caucus i call them the
republican traders it may be worse than
that
because
boeing may never really have stopped the
donations to these people and what i
mean by that is
when the january 6th riots happened in
early 2021 obviously 2020 was over so
2020 contributions were done the 2020
election was over and the 2020 calendar
year was also over now it's 2021
and they are again making contributions
so even to say that they stopped them
between january and june
when donations are really only now
ramping up and they've hit their
maximums anyway
is it really even fair to say they
stopped anything because they're
donating in june instead of in february
or march or april or may it's not even
clear to me that there was anything to
the statement that they were stopping
those donations to these traitorous
seditious individuals
we had this example earlier in the week
specifically about boeing and about
boycotts it's really hard to boycott a
company like boeing because for the most
part boeing is number one a defense
contractor and it has nothing to do with
sort of consumer facing decisions that
we make
if we wanted to boycott boeing as uh
airline passengers
we would have to figure out okay let's
see i need to go from new york city to
paris
which airlines are flying airbus planes
or
is there some other way that i can get
to florida uh without flying on a boeing
airplane it's really difficult to do
this how do you even boycott boeing and
that's part of what makes this so
pernicious now
this is not the only company that is
making donations again to the uh
traitorous treasonous republicans
pfizer intel ford cigna a t and t
they've continued to donate to political
action committees that support
many of these republican members of the
house and senate so to me
this is once again a calculated public
relations move they wanted those initial
headlines to say they are stopping the
donations to people in the house and
senate who supported stop the steal and
may have you know deliberately or or
implicitly
uh supported the january six riots it's
not even clear it ever really even meant
anything because there are limits on
political donations and okay they waited
a few months to say that they were
paused maybe of no meaning whatsoever
and we've talked about other other
examples of this last week i had the
story for you about how many companies
that are now saying we celebrate pride
month
um
have donated to both candidates and
political action committees that support
candidates that are homophobic and that
have lobbied against uh gay marriage in
in the you know the days where that was
the fight and now against so-called
religious freedom
to discriminate against people who are
or are perceived to be part of the lgbt
community we've talked about companies
who in the wake of the george floyd
protests around police brutality loudly
announced we're sending managers to
implicit bias training
which is not even clear really has any
connection whatsoever to many of the
problems that we're dealing with as far
as race goes in the united states and it
was an obvious and brazen pr move this
is much the same thing and so am i
saying boycott boeing or don't boycott
no i'm not saying anything about that
this is not about cancellation this is
about understand even something like
amazon when they announced a couple
years ago we now pay everybody 15 bucks
an hour
wow okay that's great well uh okay but
what was the pr benefit of that relative
to the cost and of course it doesn't
apply to third-party contractors that
amazon contracts with and there's so
many loopholes and end runs around it
these are mostly public relations
decisions and there is now a
sort of industry
based around making these types of
announcements while behind the scenes
they keep donating to the homophobic
politicians they keep donating to the
the sedition bunch or whatever you want
to call them and if there is really
going to be change that we want to see
we're going to have to demand more of
these companies this is really not going
to cut it and we should all be not
endlessly cynical
but healthfully skeptical when we see
such pronouncements made by these
corporations we'll have more examples of
this on the david pakman show instagram
you can follow us there at david pakman
show if you ever feel like you just
don't have enough time to read all the
books you want to read you have to check
out one of my favorite apps called
blinkist blinkist takes thousands of
popular nonfiction books and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge by
being able to soak up all of the
important insights from 10 different
books in an afternoon obviously it's
perfect for exposing yourself to a new
book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for or you can use it to revisit a book
you've already read or use it to preview
a book before you buy the full version
and read it i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video